pens one journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soit bonsoir ben souad merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
que vous inspirent ces révélations des
réseaux sociaux et à ce virus de se
sucicider effectivement il ya cette idée
selon laquelle la télé
une ag de tic tac par exemple aurait
décidé de saboter le meeting de donald
trump en demandant des billets et en
faisant croire à l'équipe de donald
trump qu'ils allaient venir et que
beaucoup de personnes voulaient venir
jour là ni ciation trump et pour sa
campagne
il est très facile de croire qu'ils
auraient beaucoup d'audience
dans le passé il ya eu beaucoup de
spectateurs au rassemblement organisé
par donald trump
donc on pouvait effectivement car cela
et si c'est effectivement une façon
d'embarrasser ton entre eux alors cela
tout à fait fonctionner car il ya une
très peu de personnes à ce rassemblement
est-ce qu'on ait une idée de qui
pourrait se cacher effectivement à ce
que ça a été organisé
d'où ça vient et ce qu'on en sait un
petit peu plus aux états unis sur ces
révélations si nous savons simplement
que certains groupes sous traitants
qu'ils en sont à l'origine
il ne s'agit pas vraiment de quoi
organiser jouer plutôt des groupes liés
aux quais pas tous âges et aux tic toc
qui ont eu cette cité spontanément de
truquer les taux d'audience là comme ça
il ne donne un train a déclaré qui
permettrait aux personnes de
s'enregistrer pour ces rassemblements
via leur téléphone grâce à leur numéro
et ces personnes donc surtout stocks ont
commencé à répandre le message qu'il
était possible d'obtenir
tickets sans s'y rendre donc il
semblerait que c'est en fait une blague
un canular qui se soit développée au
niveau du base sur tik tok et les
personnes qui ont demandé c'est touquet
m'était pas de la région et il est
difficile de dire qu'il s'agit est un
groupe organisé il s'agissait plutôt
d'une action spontanée et cela a bien
fonctionné
clairement aujourd'hui on peut dire que
tu le ça est un meeting raté pour donald
trump à un fiasco qui pourrait laisser
des traces dans la campagne
effectivement en train d'essayer de
relancer sa campagne
ils essayent de recommencer les
rassemblements et ses discours en public
on tue beaucoup de succès par le passé
et me fait que si peu de personnes se
soient présentés pourrait être dû à
plusieurs facteurs
cela pourrait d'une part être dûment par
amende enthousiasme une couverture
médiatique qui disait qu'il y avait une
affluence extrême et dont beaucoup de
personnes n'auraient pu décider de
rester chez elles plutôt que d'essayer
d'obtenir un ticket il y avait un
deuxième lieu pour un second et un
discours 'cela montre qu'il est par le
passé aucune défiance
ils vont également que si le don qui en
fait le manque d'enthousiasmé autour de
sa compagne et c'est cette question qui
reste dans les esprits jusqu'au prochain
rassemblement
alors c'est vrai que on en parle souvent
ici ensemble dans cette rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
rast une campagne tout de même troublé
il ya eu la crise bien encore d'ailleurs
puisque donald trump et évoquer encore
un bilan très lourd ce soir du coma
virus il prévoyait le décès de 150000
personnes aux états unis
le corona burrus
les émeutes en suite au décès de john de
floride
est-ce que clairement voilà c'est une
illustration de ce trou d'air que
traverse donald trump aujourd'hui et
c'est tout à fait la situation est
difficile pour demain quelques mois des
élections en novembre est désastreux n'a
plus beaucoup de temps afin de créer un
élan pour sa campagne vikings et tous
ces événements arrivent au mot vers le
mans les américains sont dans une
situation extrêmement frustrant vite les
problèmes économiques sa masse et les
problèmes sociaux également donc c'est à
ce moment que la campagne devrait
générer un élan qui n'existe pas il ya
également ce livre qui va être publié
par john bolton visant à lui lié à
exposer une présumée corruption
l'économie se porte très mal et beaucoup
de personnes se tournent vers le
président lui demandant pourquoi donc
les mois à venir vont être très
difficiles et pour moi je pense que le
président doit remplacer les directeurs
de campagne et trouver quelqu'un dessous
pourrait agir extrêmement rapide et
générer un enthousiasme important mais
je ne suis pas sûr que cela soit
possible avec tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment il ya une annonce ce soir de la
part de donald trump le gel des visas de
travail on imagine que c'est logique
dans ce contexte difficile les mecs se
replie sur elle même tribu certainement
fait de générer de l'enthousiasmé auprès
de ses électeurs et 10
avant que ces travailleurs viennent sur
notre sol et prennent les emplois des
américains
les américains doivent retrouver les
meilleurs et quand même de me sèye donc
les c'est effectivement de dire aux
travailleurs américains qui les a pas
oubliés c'est une stratégie de
temporaire donc être à voir les effets
en tout cas c'est chaque année c'est
toujours la même chose
merci ben soit que j'en ai les
investigations en direct sur arte france
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir